one of the hardest-working people in the
business RuPaul is returning to
television this January with the
upcoming scripted series AJ and the
Queen and the official trailer just
dropped and it does not disappoint AJ
and the Queen follows ruby-red a drag
queen traveling across America in an RV
with a recently orphaned 11 year old
take me to Texas hotel the witches she
touched me okay go ahead she knows me
she would never believe me stop stop
she don't know me that well you're like
a Chucky doll but not as nice I'm so
excited to make the series even more
epic 22 Queens for RuPaul's Drag Race
will also start including fan favorites
Valentina Bianca Del Rio and Trinity of
the Tuck RuPaul told Vanity Fair that
the series is edgy and has dark themes
adding it was something I was eager to
explore to prove to myself that I'm not
dead inside I proved to myself that I
could pull those emotions up it's
intoxicating last month I chatted
off-camera with Josh Segura in Montreal
about the series and he told me that he
is so proud of being part of this RuPaul
is incredible both to work with and in
the show and he said that the 11 year
old star is going to blow our minds from
the trailer I believe it I can't wait to
watch Susannah us
tear you so what do you think are you as
excited as I am will you be watching AJ
in the Queen when it premieres in
January which queens are you most
looking forward to seeing in the series
let me know in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe to ET Canada's
YouTube page